hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of red lips orange car I'm Alana
I'm joined by mod asleep and hey what's
up thanks for coming to Los Angeles to
record this just for me no other
episodes you're solely you definitely
have not referred to Los Angeles in any
other assets yeah we are right now you I
do I run our entertainment team at IGN
and usually I'm coming up to San
Francisco to hang out with you guys but
I'm glad that you are down here in my
old stomping grounds we'll go to all the
places yeah this is a show we talked
about misconnections yes you want to
start us off yes mine is not from here -
from Chicago and its title is
skateboarding down Clark Clark is a
major street is a woman seeking a man I
was stuck in an uber pool and saw you
and your tan helmet and sunglasses
flying past for a few blocks partly
intrigued and wholly jealous that you
were moving quicker than the traffic and
actually enjoying the day if you're
interested at all and hanging out and
and/or laughing at a grown-ass woman who
would genuinely like to learn how to
stand up without falling on two legs and
four wheels you know where to find me
then it's that weird emoji with like the
tongue out and the tell me what color
your Dickies were in the subject for a
response so this is very cute very
wholesome the thing I wanted to ask is
literally every girl I've ever dated has
been obsessed with skateboarders and
super attractive skateboarders and I
want to know what's up with that
skateboarding bad-boy phase I mean I
think it's like well I wonder how it's
romanticized like you know there's that
one the blonde skateboarder that
everyone just like had a crush on you
maybe not
not Tony Hawk he made it into one of the
Tony Hawk games though he had it's a
reality TV show it was basically just
like about someone like doing an extreme
sport professionally where you could
still see them so they weren't like
covered in gear like
snowboarders are sure and just kind of
money well I also think there was a well
I'll ask you Marty were you a
skateboarding no no I have no yeah and I
have no like I have no balance like if I
stood on a skateboard I'd fall and I'd
hurt myself but it was always the thing
like oh and I never like I don't know I
didn't feel threatened by it at all but
it would always just be like I'd be
walking with like a girlfriend and like
a skateboarder to go by and I hear like
I'm like what's this all about like I
understand the Chris Evans thing I feel
like we bring up Chris Evans on every
episode of V like what's your favorite
Chris Evans moment I think it's like a
different subset of things like so in
the same way that I thought dude certain
kinds of caps and bands I was like high
school I feel like those guys would have
also thought that I was cute because I
had seen him and like we'll make up like
a scene kid right it's like it's it's
just like a subculture and I also think
that especially in the 90s and early on
it's like there was nothing like the
confidence of a cute skateboarder yeah
you know like that was sort of like peak
masculinity for that time like that cool
vibe yeah it's carefree but it's also
it's funny because it's it's that
carefree thing where it's like manicured
carefree right it's like I have
manicured an image that gives off the
vibe I mean that's the thing is it's
you're an athlete cuz it's totally like
that's a sport like that's a that's
really impressive it's not like riding a
bike like skateboarding is hard
depending on what keyboarding like I can
skate I mean do you think would you
skate on a busy street and not be
worried about getting hit by a car
yeah absolutely I don't know but the
interesting thing is I feel like at a
certain age there's an age cap on
skateboarding I think or at least a like
I don't know if you're in your 30s
boarding just because there's San
Francisco we see you know like when we
work in solo which there's like a lot of
tech companies down there and startups
and everything and like you'll see dudes
probably make a lot more money than I
sound like razor scooters and stuff is
like what's going on here like what you
would just walk like on a skateboard I
look at that as someone who like never
quite grew up which is probably judgy
sure but if I'm like seeing someone in
like a business suit skateboarding to
work I'm like there's probably you
probably could afford a lift they're
like 50 years old in Australia who's
still soft though and I don't feel about
that I don't feel that way about surfing
yeah I feel I was doing a cosplay shoot
for my spider going maybe three weeks
ago now and we have to like retake a
bunch of shots because there were these
guys skateboarding down the hill that we
were shooting on yeah and they all would
have been like 35 and it was actually
kind of sweet because it was like a
group of grown men taking tons skating
down the hill filming each other on
their iPhones and like clapping when
someone did something cool yeah if you
like a difference between that is like
with at least going back to snowboarding
and surfing is that those aren't modes
of transportation and theories their
hobbies like you're surfing you're not
trying to get from point A to point B it
can be a hobby but like this thing like
you can take a skateboard to work so you
can be like a bicycle where it says it's
ostensibly your car yeah sure like I
think this connection is really cute
yeah it's like it's a really interesting
one though because it's seems like her
only draw like I guess unless she got it
good look at the guy who was solely that
he was skating this actually didn't seem
to know it like she was like he's
wearing this color but like she said he
was moving really quickly like to
achieve and see his face moving really
quickly he had a helmet on he was
wearing Dickies and I'm like that's kind
of just anyone on a skateboard a little
hilarious to that she's just like
shooting up this flare of like they they
want to learn how to skateboard maybe
you don't seem like you're good at it
random person I can't even get a
yeah my best shot is writing this yeah
yeah whereas I just probably like he
should be a skateboard lesson in LA
there's a class I'm writing this wall in
the cost like this is the hidden here
maybe she could look into a skateboard
man by learning to skate like is it just
someone who's like he's having fun I
kind of want to do that she was like hmm
from what I can vaguely see of him
because she's not approaching it in a
way that seems like she wants to have
sex which is also like a thing that I
imagine you think of when you're doing
one of those because you don't get a
bunch of unsolicited dick pics basically
so it's like I think if you're a woman
posting one like that you'd be like I'm
gonna make this very platonic I wonder
what she's like she didn't use the
classic this is not sexual line like so
many of these have been that was that's
so that she would know it was the right
skateboarder yeah yeah so do we have a
name so we give everyone a name all of
our characters are named skate Kate or
tony hawk or than i the other thing so
this was Chicago on January 31st
you know what's incredibly [ __ ] cold
Chicago I was in Chicago a month before
this and it was negative 20 degrees he
was warm and toasty I know maybe
for skateboarding around the city like
[Music]
an interesting conversation about like
the fact that you can find just like
certain kinds of clothes on people
attractive just like yeah you wear that
kind of clothing and I like it like it's
weird
yeah I mean so that was the thing is
like again I've known a lot of girls who
are like I am attracted to skateboarders
like I don't know what the equivalent of
that it's like it's totally like a
hairstyle a makeup style like it's
totally those are the people who date
but you also go from the range of like
guys who like super preppy girls to guys
who like super club' girls style no but
I don't think I don't know if I have one
that like associates with a hobby tend
to I could that style like most people
who skateboard dress in a certain way
like wet Dickies like I could have
guessed if you like guess what he's
wearing like Vance Lee it's like super
easy to guess that right yes like
baseball tees like that's like a common
thread there which is it's very
interesting people can be like I maybe
it's that based on just literally
someone wearing a certain brand you have
innocently maybe it's good marketing you
have an assumption of what that post
Melanie will be like what the interest
will be if you know like actually did
like an audit I mean you found
attractive like you'll find that through
line I remember like six years ago at a
certain point like all my celebrity
crushes and my real life crushes and the
guy I was dating like I realized all
looked exactly the same like everyone
was sort of like duplicates of Mike my
boyfriend like Emile Hirsch and kind of
changed me recently I definitely had a
type and since I hit like 20 it's been
like way more broad like but before that
I was absolutely boy su skateboard boys
who I like ball caps with the flat brim
ones tattoos baseball tees I love how
you've named everything but none of
these are played
does wear baseball tees constantly it's
my shot this is Kojima Pro shot that is
black and has like writing on the side
there looks like something that a dude
who's in a band or like a scene dude
it's it's odd look I wonder if that kind
of tastes like machines and stuff too or
just like yeah roses you meet more
people because like a lot of the people
I was friends with in high school world
of same kind of people I think they all
listen to the same music we all went to
the same but also I feel like when you
get older like you aren't in just that
one place of high school or college or
whatever where everything is you can
just have the same group like I find
that I have different groups of friends
that I have sort of different types of
things I do with like you don't just
have one group that does everything you
sort of find you're just aggressively
popular I'm not no I just go to brunch
with the same people every weekend
that's true yeah I put my foot down on
that yeah all right Terry you're up so
this is a woman seeking man or woman for
man in Los Feliz which is the
neighborhood next to my old neighborhood
of Silver Lake so I was like trying to
find neighborhoods that I knew and this
is you paid for my items at Albertson's
which is a grocery store next to the guy
in the black hoodie who paid for my
items at aalverson Albertsons on
Hillhurst Friday night when my credit
card wouldn't go through thank you so
much what an incredibly kind gesture I
was so surprised by your generosity that
I didn't get a chance to ask her name I
had a tough week at work and you totally
made my night
if you're reading this I would love to
make it up to you I hope your reply
thanks again and I just thought that was
the nicest story yeah I love it and I
did like I don't know if you guys feel
this way sometimes it's just so easy to
get into the grind we live in cities
where there are so many homeless people
people are angry like there's this whole
spectrum and I know like sometime
I'm just like cranky and an uber or
something or sometimes I'm feeling
really great and I love this because I
feel like it is those little moments
especially in a big city where you're
just nice to someone to be nice
it leaves such an impact and I love that
this person was like I just had a really
tough week and this was the thing that
made everything better and like you
never know how the small little I
granted this guy bought her groceries I
don't know if it was like two items are
torn yeah but I feel like I just thought
that was really sweet and again
especially in a city where people aren't
sure in the city that's sort of like
thrives in anonymity and so I feel like
this one isn't inherently sexual I think
this is a person just genuinely being
like hey you had such a positive impact
on me I'll buy you lunch or something
yeah exactly like you showed me human
kindness
like what do you think the nicest thing
a stranger has ever done feels like if
we count complete stranger it's
different in our line of work that I had
people like when I spoke about my dog
dying who sent me packets of Tim Tams
which is like my favorite Australian
biscuit people that I like didn't know
very well yeah it happened like two
people did that it was just like the
nicest [ __ ] thing in the world was
like things like that kind of don't
count but there was this probably
2009-2010 I was at brunch with my
girlfriend at the time and we were in a
place in San Francisco and there's
probably I don't know like 30 people
eating brunch now and at a certain point
the server went up to every table and
was like hey this is weird
a gentleman who just left put down his
card and he wants to pay for everyone's
meal the entire restaurant and we were
like no literally everyone in the
restaurant so wasn't just like he knew
me well I was working at a coffee shop
he knew who I was but like he like
everyone and they're like so but it
wasn't a person that you were like oh no
like and I was like which guy was he
like he was over there like he was
sitting at the bar by himself and I was
like like that must've been like our
meal was probably 40 50 bucks and we
were one of 10
what if I could just do that thing that
would make things nicer like I didn't
I'm sure that there are so many things
that I'm forgetting but like thinking of
just LA as a city I remember it was like
the second day when I moved here I was
21 I thought like you know everyone LA
was supposed to be rude it sort of
shitty and I was in my neighborhood who
sort of walking around and I was with my
friend and I just like asked a question
out loud like to my friend but like
openly like you know how far are we away
for your like whatever and this woman
just like was walking down the street
and just stopped and stood there and
talked to us for like five or ten
minutes and like gave us all the
information with the way of the line and
I was like you know this whole
stereotype of again like you know people
being flaky and superficial but I just
found like that you just stopped and
talked to a stranger because it was the
nice thing to do that just sort of stuck
with me as being like oh yeah I guess
you can do that yes your story kind of
bums me out though cuz I wish they would
have like I wish she wasn't like I was
taken aback and I was in Russian so I
didn't get like this is one of those
where I'm like you kind of [ __ ] up
like you should have talked to the guy
and been like thank you so much what is
this scenario can I buy you coffee can I
get you a drink like right so this is a
weird parallel that I hope like I don't
tell wrong I had paid I've paid for
someone's groceries before and it was in
a negative circumstance we were in a
chain in Australia that's called Aldi
and it was the guy who was in front of
me and he was drunk and he was abusing
the person behind the cash register and
was just being a piece of [ __ ] and his
card wasn't walking and he was just
being awful to everyone so this is back
when I was like to talk about it like in
the good old days when I was [ __ ]
cashed up because I'm on TV so I was
just like okay I'm gonna deal with this
by paying for this dude's groceries to
get him out of the store and that's what
I did was just like pay for this get
this dude the [ __ ] out you know I'm not
leaving anyway we had to get security to
get him out but the point was like
that's kind of what my head went to with
this is like that's only because it's a
personal relation that I was like when I
did that for someone it was because I
was like I want this person as far away
from me as possible and it's possible
she was having a really shitty week in
her car she was being dick and he was
like I just want to [ __ ] get my stuff
and get out of here I know and I'm sorry
but I was like I'm sorry that like this
is in theory sweet and and the fact that
she posted this makes me think that she
didn't feel like he was being hostile
which is just a nice thing to do
the time it happened to me was me being
like I want to buy myself out of this
situation
yeah and it's like totally possible that
happened too and he was just like get me
the [ __ ] out of here I'm never gonna
talk to you ever again but it's also if
I was this guy and had done that in the
positive way I think most people would
be uncomfortable with following up on it
like most people would be like no no no
this wasn't like a charity thing I don't
want you to repay me this is just a
thing that I did like say thank you and
move on right like oh yeah I would
totally not be I would be like you don't
need to be because she doesn't shoes
even describe him physically at all
right yes neither these people at their
ages right so you don't know if these
two the guy in the black hoodie so she
is that as much yeah I just I liked it
in a sea of people just trying to get
laid I was like this is this is a nice
one but I did I did have a backup that I
can share with you guys or do it we want
to wait into the end because I it was
that an Albertsons we just keep
associating like this person would be
yeah yeah I don't have any associations
for shauna you gotta stop saying like
that right who's the guy the guy in the
black hoodie moneybags over here I'm
gonna go with mine now because of based
on what you guys picked I was like all
right I'm gonna I'm gonna find this I
have a bunch of Bank so this one is from
Oakland it's called China Doll man phone
woman hello China if you're reading this
I'm young
that we lost contact over five years ago
you used to stay right next to the
police station in downtown Oakland and I
believe you're on house arrest oh you
had to check in with your Pio like once
a week I think about you every day
and then I lost a connection with you
hopefully you're out there reading this
some way and that you and I can get
together your youngster b-body athletic
status single okay I went way over my
head in that one okay so I used to the
first few years I lived in the Bay Area
I lived relatively close to the Oakland
Police Department China's clearly a
prostitute that's what I think yes and
so China would hang out near the the
funny thing about Oakland is a lot of
the prostitutes hung out very close to
the police station I assumed China was a
prostitute also but why would so it's I
believe you're on house arrest or you
had to check in with your Pio like once
a week she's on house arrest that means
she's no longer if she was still a
prostitute hanging out there it'd be
easy to find her that's not a miss
connection you just go to the corner
that's what you lived that's I don't
know if it was it's downtown like there
are apartments yeah we're ahead like an
SRO yeah so the the one question I have
about this is he keeps referring to as
young stuff yeah that's yeah I mean that
might have like maybe they literally had
a connection where she referred to him
as youngster right like I mean maybe my
I don't I've you it as she was in her
40s or 50s was in his twenties or
thirties interesting I see I pictured
like it all being slightly young I don't
know why but then I'm also like super
interested in the context that he they
they saw each other at some point
we lost contact means that he wasn't
necessarily a client of hos because it
seemed like they had two contacts I mean
I just felt like he either worked at the
police station or worked
that area and like she was a person who
he would walk by every day no I just it
says I think about you every day and
then I'll see connection with you
hopefully you're out there someone
reading this and then you and I can get
together a lot of these are written with
you get the idea I also I like how even
if this is a a prostitute John scenario
which might not be like that was just
immediately where I went to because
china doll that's what it is but it
could also just be a dude who had a
slightly racist nickname for a Chinese
woman right when you said China dollar
was a key have you said like it's seems
kind of sweet and wholesome also despite
the fact that there's like parole he
knew she sorry she knew and was okay
with being called china doll that's why
the china doll thing is what made me
think that they had slept together if
it's just China Oakland Police
Department is also one block away from
Oakland's Chinatown which is like full
like like San Francisco's Chinatown is
like legitimate Chinese people living
there who speak Chinese yeah that's the
thing is I want to know what their
relationship was that they have
affectionate names for each other
seemingly but he says we lost contact
over five years ago and he doesn't know
if she was on house arrest I'll have to
check in with the PIO once a week so
what is that relationship I see I view
it as something like maybe he was even
someone who was in a similar scenario
but like I think about how many people
you what would walk by all the time or
like recognize in your neighborhood and
just sort of like know them even if you
didn't know them and like create a story
for them there are two of the guys at
the coffee shop that we often go to that
I just like kind of love that I like
enjoy talking to and I'm happy to see
them and like if I go in by myself
especially I'll have like a full
conversation with them that I would
never host something like this but if I
if they left I would be sad if I didn't
get to say goodbye too right
one of them's name is Akira you know
that because he's very nice and I like
him alone I've had really good chats
with sort of what I feel like it feels
like someone who didn't actually know
this person but knew them enough in
passing that like they're like this is
where you always work this is where we
saw each other and I haven't seen ya
that's the mark of some sort sort of
like yeah I mean like that relationship
where like it wasn't like a deep-rooted
relationship but it's something like
weeds like every day and so like you see
these people one of the conversations I
have with Akira when I was working late
the other night was I always thought
about getting anything else it was like
so the backstory to that is that I love
Australian coffee and I don't think u.s.
coffee is generally very good and that's
when it's like no base coffee like
coffee is really good it's amazing and I
order the thing that it's the closest
that I can get to what Australian coffee
tastes like and I will order always
order the same thing because it like
tastes like home and anywhere else I go
whatever else I get like sure I would be
trying different things but it doesn't
taste like what it is that what your
family we all have the same thing so
it's like I ordered the thing that that
tastes like home and I told him that he
was like I'm so glad that we can do that
for you like it was just this really
nice interaction that again if that guy
left because they like shuffled through
people quite a bit there I would be sad
to not be like hey thank you for making
me coffee for the past year or whatever
like it would be genuinely sad I would
never have an affectionate nickname for
him like youngster though that's the
thing that makes me think their
relationship is at least floody like
because i am yo youngster and he says
you're young right
she could just be like an older woman
who's super confident who just like
throughout it and it came to this guy
who like she sees occasionally yeah the
ends it would be Davis Robinson
that's really good we didn't quite get
to the bottom of this so youngster I
think he's affectionate she may have
been on house arrest so I don't think
they meant in passing its potential she
was a prostitute and that that's why she
hung out and mm-hmm
house arrest me she has to stay home
though right could she have been like
standing on her stoop is that downtown
Oakland wouldn't have Stoops like there
is like there's stoop like in San
Francisco I think he is the Chief of
Police
Oakland's Chief of Police you think Brad
- I think the sequel to Brad known as
youngster the information oh wait
youngster could be a joke he could be
like 70s like youngster could be ironic
guys I don't think he was the police
station I really don't think maybe he
would have to go to the yeah do you guys
think that they have questions about
this one it's sort of sweet to me it's
sweet and I feel like if they would have
ever had like a thing like a sexual
encounter that something like it would
have gotten brought up or something a
bit more like vulgar and adult because
it really never like it never gets
beyond like PG here but me but I think
that the fact that he's like I think
about you every day
five years later makes me think that
either she had a story that was really
affecting like him to be like the most
sincere volson version of that or he
always had like a little bit of a crush
on her
is thinking about her like whatever
happened that person and now is trying
this route so who of these is most
likely to succeed in making their
connections between Brad to Kate I mean
I feel like skate Kate is probably least
likely like that guy is speeding on the
speed of life yeah down the streets and
skateboards I think it's likely been
Chyna am I thinking with Chyna is they
haven't seen each other for five years
right so there's a chance Chyna moved
okay one was we hadn't seen each other
since 1972 so yeah there's a solid
chance they died in the 50 years since
then yeah I don't know there's only a
handful of people who are alive in 1972
who are still my parents see this is
like like the china doll situation with
young steuby I always want to roll those
out because it's so unlikely that these
two people have met five years ago was
going to meet again but again he
specifies like I feel like Terry yours
might be the most likely I think the
thing that gives me hope about yours is
that like someone else might know and be
able to help that's true yeah because
there's enough details here well I guess
the only three people who would know in
this scenario would be the girl the guy
in the black hoodie or the cashier right
my thing is like Richie Rich just has so
much cash money flowing around that he
probably doesn't need to look at
misconnection
not they might meet each other again
because most people shop at the same
grocery all right if you're a neighbor
like they're in the same vicinity at
least we know that so I think I think
Richie Rich is most likely yeah like
everyone's like I run into people I know
in my neighborhood at the grocery store
I'm gonna put Richie Rich at the top of
the list
yeah so why so if we're between actually
yeah I would love to give them like
what's his real name
it's either well know China's probably
not her real name it's possible there
was a wrestling name it was her she
could be a wrestler that the plot
thickens yeah that's Hawaiian her name
I'm sorry I think I think this one is
more likely than skate cake yeah there's
not enough details in skate Cate and
clearly the dude who's actually skating
doesn't give a [ __ ] about this girl also
again he was skateboarding on January
31st and he's done he found us noblank
and we'll see him in april when the fall
comes absolutely r.i.p him but that one
is also other people reading it in
Chicago couldn't be like hey I found
this about you because it's too big yes
I feel like she might I have dreams
first get cake no one's gonna teach her
if she keeps doing the door thing
everyone who's listening I know that the
winky eye with the tongue sticking out
is easier to find than the regular wink
but it's there just use the regular ring
do you I do I do like the kids use that
to the teens like it it used to be like
I just couldn't find the regular wink
and that one that kept coming up no I
totally season sexting why do you need
emojis like that in sexting do you wink
during sex it's like
sometimes sometimes I've my glasses off
some I squint times when you're a woman
seeking man who just wants to suck a
guy's D you know you're trying to do the
deed but it like gets in your eye and
then you know that's a good point yeah
that's actually a perfect example that
that is actually possible as oh you came
on my face yeah so there's the eggplant
emoji
splash emoji well that person clear that
information you can find me on all the
social media at mcbaggy MCB IgG ITT wine
you can find me on Twitter teri
underscores works sometimes keeps me up
at night thinking about how kids will
eventually oh oh and they're just gonna
have to have like a bunch of numbers in
Robert Horry letters until like Gmail
was like that has not been taken here's
a suggestion for you and it's just like
a bunch of [ __ ] Oh Jim Smith or just
or just out clever each other like
charlottas art there's like [ __ ]
there's like a thousand Pokemon
you just put a lot in the middle of any
of this [ __ ] buh buh honest or and if
you need any yeah jiggly Ilana puffs
yeah that's actually my that's right
yeah yeah when we're playing with
destiny yeah
Terry underscore underscore underscore
dactyl reckoner because Netflix and I
forgot that like people actually use it
what was that recommend was ridiculous
thing I can come up with death reckoner
and then I started playing like hey
there's two things wrong with this
you're nice and real life is video games
because it's like a would like tackiest
and then like so tackiest pants is one
of my favorite ones and then it'll be
like he's tatty asleep ants at a tee
like they're the Tati's to pee oh the
fattiest
yeah it'll be like like just it's it's
always like a descriptor and then just a
thing so like just a descriptor and then
an object so there's like one that's
like touched feline is what my stepdads
is so it's like you know you can change
that yeah because they also use like
uncommon descripting ones yeah if you
want to send us some nice words you can
tweet at us with the hashtag RL Lucy and
find us also we have bonus episodes on
patreon at patreon.com slash challenge
that see you guys next time